this guy has a sex question for ronnie
i'm a recently divorced 48 year old man
now that i'm back out there i realized
that i need to start shaving downstairs
ronnie talks like an expert
ball and [ __ ] shaver can you ask him
about his technique i can't shave my
nuts without cutting myself
and as far as my [ __ ] i have no idea
what's going on back there and i have no
way of seeing where i'm shaving i'm
[ __ ] lost help me ron
help me ron you do shave it right yeah
and do you have a tip it's easy i mean
you know you just make sure you uh you
lather up really good with good you know
a nice uh shaving gel you know
yeah and after you do it a few times
like your skin gets used to it
i mean i've never cut myself you're
completely
shaven down there no just my balls and
ass
you shave your butt raise her in your
ass
[Music]
you heard her you put a razor in your
ass
yes it's uh the power glide and do you
clean it afterwards
yeah no i use this i have a separate i
use a separate blade just for
for trimming so when i shave my face
it's a different blade i don't use the
same blade for that
but i'm saying even even the the blade
you use for your [ __ ] i mean
i mean of course i clean it and i'm in
the shower so
it's clean dude i still talking about it
why are you so angry i'm not i'm not
angry
it's like you're yelling it out i'm just
asking yeah well that's
that's what you do i mean you lather up
really good and once your
your skin gets used to it you know and
you gotta you know keep
up with it every week you lather up with
an electric razor
in your ass no you put it on not an
electric razor it's it's what is it
regular
blade yeah it's odor
i don't stick it in my [ __ ] you just
like spread your [ __ ] open you just
trim
it's not like i [ __ ] shave it like i
shave my face like to make sure
everything is gone
why do you do that is it because your
girlfriend puts the dildos in your ass
and you don't want her to see hair or
and she tongues your ass i just i just
like i like it clean
because when you take a [ __ ] and
everything it's when you wipe your ass
it comes out a lot cleaner you know
and and with in the front that's the
same
um electric razor and you can gel up and
yeah yeah on your balls yeah my
balls yeah i want to see it and do you
stretch it
the skin or is it you know yes just yes
oh you stretched
the skin you do you scratch you stretch
the skin so you get why does
why does robin have to ask you all these
why do rob why does robin have to ask
you all these questions i say to you how
do you do it and you're like you just do
it man
and then robin asks you and then all of
a sudden there's always a technique
she's asking for full details i'm just
kidding
well that guy he says i don't know how
to do it well now he knows
all right listen i'm going to talk to
david crosby he's got a lot more on his
mind than shaving his [ __ ] i don't
think well maybe not
i think it's safe to say that crosby
stills nash and young never shaved their
[ __ ] but yeah
i i i wouldn't be so sure about that
dude